[Music]
and another one from this is a good one
though this but they're almost good but
this one's this is a Bobby Lee does it
go both ways yeah I hear about yours no
I don't tell them well I mean there's
I'm gonna say one thing there's one
piece of [ __ ] comic
I'm sorry I'm not gonna say his name
he's a loser I don't know right and he
texted me today hey do you do you mind
if I asked kalila out on a date
which is [ __ ] a [ __ ] hey at least
Brennan was polite enough to ask this
time
okay very funny Bravo sir
good line that was a great intro line
for this one I'd say that's some
progress no I'm just kidding that's a
joke Brendan please don't sue me
[Laughter]
him Dylan they're referring to it turns
out Tim Dillon's been faking being gay
this whole time and he's just been
hitting on other comedians wives and
girlfriends no I'm just kidding those
are both jokes but if either one of
those were true I'd respect him a lot
more as a comedian because that'd be the
funniest thing they've ever done like
could you imagine if he isn't the only
comic and she just makes the worst
experience ever that is he isn't the
only comic who's asked by the way
listen Comics listen to me right now off
off that's not cool man it's not yeah
yeah I don't get a sailor so you're good
like saying no Comics No one that Bobby
would I would not no more remotely in
his Circle I'm not interested because
but in your family it's fine yeah your
brother's okay but not as long as you're
in your family it's it's fine right okay
cool or if it's on four legs with him or
just because dating a comic or if it's
true if it's chipped if it's a chipped
animal she'll also that's fine it's not
what you want to do again it's something
I never even want to come close to doing
like any lifetime she'll be dating a
comic within six months why
I think it's absolutely traumatizing
everything
uh you know what's wrong sometimes your
brother into an early grave by [ __ ]
them yeah and you traumatize your
[ __ ] dog every time you shut up and
[ __ ] hide
I think it is one if it's not for the
faint of heart and you will get dragged
through them no no no no
let me just be clear here it is Bobby's
fault that she latched on to him and she
could have been his girlfriend without
being on his show she chose to be on his
show so Bobby's not the reason you're
getting dragged if you were getting
dragged and you were just like somebody
working a desk job people would be like
that's kind of [ __ ] up man leave leave
us yeah she's not doing anything but you
latched onto it you used it to catapult
yourself into your own show hanging out
and interviewing Real comics and people
like that you made a career out of it
but also it's horrible because people
are mean to you and it's Bobby's fault
so you want all the good that came out
of it but also any bad is Bobby's fault
you're self-made but Bobby made you got
it makes sense because now why don't you
write another poem about it you hack
no not me though you know I'm sure it is
hard dating a comedian and especially
Bobby Lee but just because you're dating
your comedian doesn't mean you need to
drag through the mud by the fans I think
is what she's referring by the way I've
noticed two laces making his videos more
and more transformative so they don't
[ __ ] with him now he's acting like the
picture of him growing and stuff too
like doesn't Burke Chrysler have his
wife on his show sometimes I don't think
she really gets any hate like maybe just
the normal hate people get on the
internet yeah I don't know honestly
because she's not hateable and you're a
hatable color that's the difference I
don't like there's a lot of people who I
follow who are watching the shows or I'm
like a fan of their comedian comedy and
stuff I have no idea who they're dating
no clue and I don't care you know what I
mean if you're gonna not thrust yourself
into the spotlight and then also be a
psychopath like you're just
independently unlikable there's nothing
to do with it's not a backlash from
Bobby's audience you're a hateable woman
everything you've done is terrible
and you should feel shame but I think
you lack that like part of your brain
only because like the the payoff of like
a really like you are so [ __ ] cute
and funny
thank you
um but never again never again because
you know I already use this for to get
where I needed to be never all right why
what let's what's like the breaking
point what's the what's the thing that
you could tell girls that are like I'm
gonna date a comic like what you what
are they what's what do you mean drag
through them like what is it yeah I'm
[ __ ]
super [ __ ] sure that if someone at
like Rogan's level of com of Comedy came
up to you've called me came up to you
and said they wanted to date you that
you were gonna go no sorry no Comics you
such a [ __ ] liar the problem is let
me just answer for real she will date a
comic but it has to be now a higher tier
comic than Bobby Lee
it has to be you know you're saying what
I'm saying like she will [ __ ] her way up
at least equal to she will talk her way
up yeah
I think you're the exception Bobby are
you being real I'm being real okay thank
you I think there are exceptions to this
clearly give me another exception give
me another exception Sebastian
absolutely Sebastian Maniscalco Louie
I'm just kidding
absolutely absolutely
you know we broke up yeah okay how do
you feel about that I was sad okay it
was like it was kind of like the comedy
community was a I I at least
the comedy community why the comedy
community
why would you care people break up all
the [ __ ] time
it was bummed to hear it but then I was
happy to see I checked in on you guys
afterwards I'm sorry who is she I'm not
trying to be a dick I'm not trying to
say that she looks familiar but she does
I cannot I cannot somebody will tell us
I'm sure long still cohabitating kind of
still sleeping in the same but is that
still going on no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no I think
that was the last time I checked no no
no no no no no yeah all right so anyway
I'm on the dating apps
and um doing all right yeah crushing
yeah crushing it yeah not crushing it
but I've met a couple people this is a
big turnaround I listen to the Harlan
Williams episode today
Harlan Williams like from Down Periscope
yeah Rocket Man rocket man we watched
that one didn't we oh we did oh it was
so bad this is when you go I'm never
getting never never gonna happen never
gonna go on a date that was only five
that was five weeks ago it wasn't that
long ago yeah Nikki Glasser oh okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's still okay
yeah three weeks ago yeah yeah and so
never okay so which one are you uh Raya
obviously oh no that's dead zone why
I've I've never matched with I matched
with one girl and I like her we're the
rich dudes
right and she
and I don't know if this is real or not
but I set up a date for her this Sunday
but then she said she's sick today she
texts me she's sick and she says I might
have to pass on Sunday so I don't I
think that's that's that's fair no he's
a fair or my being no one gets sick I'm
sorry yeah so Bob that was kind of funny
that was very funny nobody gets sick
that's pretty good all right so I mean
again it it is it's just just like I
want to know who asked I need to know
who but whoever it is he's not happy
with obviously